what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with way of x but before we get
into this i want to clear a few things
up yes jonathan hickman is quote unquote
leaving marvel but not permanently he's
actually working on something different
at marvel he's still contributing a
little bit to the x-men line it's really
more of like kind of operating on the
back end as an organizational thing and
two he is going to sub stack along with
like james tinian and a whole bunch of
other great big huge writers sub stack
is basically an all digital version of
like image comics in effect and hickman
is writing like three moons three worlds
and they're all kind of building a
shared universe together so imagine if
image comics was like marvel comics and
then it was only digital and that's
basically sub stack uh having said that
so the way of x basically focuses on the
return of onslaught right it's one of
the things we talked about in the last
few videos that onslaught was coming
back but the way this was handled was
really really cool right so the overall
gist here was that onslaught for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar with this
onslaught's probably one of the most
amazing villains that marvel ever had in
the history of the x-men line and he was
an insanely powerful even in his base
form right he's a combination of
professor x's frustration with humanity
combined with magneto's hatred of
humanity on the psychological level that
merged into a singular being right and
then following that he took the powers
of x-men nate grey where at least
absorbed x-man nate grey which just gave
him insane telepathic and telekinetic
powers which were way beyond what he
already had and then he absorbed
franklin richards when he was a little
kid which made him even more powerful
because then he could alter reality
right so this guy was an absolute hoss
right if you want to know more about
onslaught i believe we have a beyond
omega level video on onslaught if we
don't i don't know why we wouldn't uh
that'll be down in the description he's
insanely powerful but the overall gist
here is that the hunt for onslaught or
trying to figure out how onslaught's
coming back or why he's coming back or
even when he's coming back has really
come down to legion and nightcrawler and
the reason for this is pretty simple and
very elegant the way that it was handled
it was basically keeping it small and
legion is probably one of the only
mutants out there that could actually go
toe-to-toe with onslaught because one
thing to keep in mind when it comes to
david holler in his in his normal human
form right is i guess you know david
prime if you want to call him that he's
already absurdly powerful in terms of
his telepathy but then when you add add
to the fact that he's got thousands of
personalities in his head each one has a
power of their own it makes him one of
the most powerful mutants in existence
he can do anything from controlling
people's emotions to altering reality
it's crazy the kind of stuff that he can
do but one of the things they're doing
is keeping it small because the reality
is everybody knows that onslaught
originated from magneto and professor x
and under any normal circumstance that
wouldn't matter but those guys are
running cricoa
and so if you found out that the psychic
amalgamation of just frustration and
rage is returning and that it originated
from the people who were running your
country you would probably flee
that's most likely what you would do and
so if everybody else found out that
onslaught was coming back it would
completely and totally destroy
everything krakow stands for and so
while while david and them aren't really
doing it for any altruistic purpose
right like we really want to spare
magneto and xavier the humiliation of
basically knowing that like their love
child their psychic love child is
returning it's really more to ensure
that this nation of cocoa does not
collapse along this journey there's a
couple things that go on here there's
not not really huge things but a couple
small things to go on here the first
thing is that you have a couple mutants
named mercury and loa and they are in
effect not really losing control of
their powers but having a hard time
coping with their powers and for the
most part that's not a major plot thread
but the reason why you end up seeing
legion get involved here is because he's
basically using them as bait that if he
can enter into their mind using its
telepathy and then help them kind of
better understand each other their
powers can work in unison work closer so
on so forth it'll also give him the
ability to fish out onslaught to see if
onslaught is among them or potentially
anybody that they came into contact with
and it actually works right in the
process when he gets inside their minds
they're kind of joined minds that he
ends up finding onslaught and then
rooting him out now as soon as onslaught
realizes he's discovered he takes off
right he immediately bails and just
jumps to the next person now that's
something that i do want to talk about
here for a second you wouldn't think
that that a being this powerful would
run away right you wouldn't really think
that would happen then instead it would
stand and it would challenge uh david
but that's one thing to keep in mind the
original onslaught saga was exactly like
that right when onslaught first
manifested he hid inside the mind of
charles xavier nobody really knew that
he was there right his origin came from
really the idea or it really started
with the fatal attraction story when
charles xavier had shut down all of
magneto's powers after he basically
ripped the adamantium out of wolverine
and then when a mutant was killed just
outside the xavier institute that was
the breaking point right and that's
where when when xavier had shut down
magneto's powers he had absorbed a
portion of his consciousness in the
process and then when that little kid
was killed it all just came together and
then it basically you know resulted in
onslaught being born and then he just
hid he just stayed as this kind of
colonel inside the mind of of xavier but
appearing every once in a while just
small little things right creating
dissent creating discord among the ranks
of not just the mutants in in the the
x-men institute but the overall mutant
population until it was strong enough to
be able to make it on its own and then
it showed up right and it really kind of
happened when the x-men realized what
was going on that something was wrong
with xavier and when they confronted him
that's when onslaught manifested and
then all hell broke loose right so
that's kind of what what is really going
on here in a more broad scale it's
basically the the essence of onslaught
just jumping from person to person now
following that you kind of pick up with
nightcrawler here who is following the
events when he was drunk during the gala
nightcrawler got drunk a man of god was
getting drunk on the sacrament so the
important thing here is that he ends up
coming across stacy x now stacy x is
kind of a cool mutant her powers are
really what make her cool not her as a
person right her powers are awesome so
she's a lot like rogue in the sense that
she her powers only really impact you if
they touch you but she can basically
emit pheromones that can do everything
from make you experience incredible
sensations of love to literally crapping
your pants right it just it depends on
what it is that she wants to do with you
but come to find out what stacy x has
been doing is running a place called the
bauer which is basically a brothel
there's a brothel inside of the inside
the nation of cacao and it kind of makes
sense right one of the things that's
really happened when it came to cocoa is
we've only really seen the political
slash conflict side right on the home
front one of the things we learn here
that makes perfect sense is there are
mutants on kakoa who one don't want to
get with humans right because you know
it's kind of shunned it's not really
illegal within krakowa but it's kind of
looked down upon right like getting into
a relationship with a normal human
because humans are largely kind of
considered to be the enemy uh and so
there are a lot of mutants around here
that aren't really looking for like a
long-term romantic relationship they
just want to bang and so you end up
going to the power right and that's
where everybody just basically hooks up
and that's essentially it but the other
part of this and that's kind of the
funny thing is that when you have this
kind of thing taking place one of the
things that's alluded to here is there
isn't really any method of protection
between these various mutants right and
so this basically results in kids being
born and and one of the darker elements
here is that these kids are largely just
kind of abandoned they're left in this
sort of hatchery or this is this kind of
place where you know the kids are
is really more like an orphanage than
anything else and that eventually
they'll grow up right and they they may
or may not be adopted by other mutants
whatever the case is uh they'll go on to
become productive members of society
it's kind of messed up when you think
about it but one of the cool things
about this is you actually end up
finding out that there is a mutant named
lost that's basically a part of this now
lost is a very new creation in marvel
comics right like literally created
during the way of x series the way this
worked is that lost was at one point a
mutant who just existed out there but
her parents were basically killed by
fabian cortez and the acolytes sometime
before the events of at least the events
of the past we don't really know when
we're not really given like the
circumstance in terms of how it unfolded
we're just told that it did so there's
basically a big kind of vendetta between
lost and uh and fabian cortez but more
so than that lost has the ability to
distort gravity around her and so uh
that's why she hangs out here where the
where the kids are as opposed to with
anybody else because the effect of her
powers basically gives people vertigo
and so they just end up getting nauseous
puking their guts up and so nobody
really hangs out with her but when
fabian cortez ends up showing up here on
the scene a fight kind of breaks out
between the two of them now under normal
circumstances this wouldn't happen but
again onslaught is influencing the
people around here and so when onslaught
kind of taken off from loa and mercury
it had landed inside of lost and then
david holler in them basically managed
to track onslaught down and then of
course onslaught manifests itself for
like a split second and basically sends
everybody flying and while no one really
seems to understand exactly what was
going on legion does legion and
nightcrawler know exactly what was
happening that onslaught manifested for
a split second just sent everybody out
of there and then called it a day so you
end up picking up on basically mars
which again is kind of a satellite place
for the mutants to hang out right kind
of an extension of kokoa and it's really
their own nation right literally like
the mutant population is terraformed
mars and now like there's a huge there's
a huge portion of them living there or
at least uh storm is the one who governs
it but the big kind of discussion here
is what are we going to do about
onslaught right how is this going to
work like what are we going to do with
this this kind of massive threat here
and so you have this kind of uh brief
reprieve where legion returns to gracoa
and has a conversation with charles
xavier and this is when everything
starts to pop off right because as
xavier is talking to legion one of the
things to keep in mind is they've always
had a very contentious history with each
other a lot of it was because of it it
really goes back to the nature of david
and the simpson as the child of gabriel
holler and charles xavier that legion's
powers were just wild and it was very
difficult to kind of corral these
personalities or to even understand the
nature of his powers and so despite him
not really having a desire to do so at
the end of the day it was in the
interest of everybody involved if legion
was basically subjected to
experimentation at the hands of xavier
moore mctaggart not really brutal
experimentation but to kind of
understand his powers more so than that
legion was insane back in the day so you
started seeing things like uh the legion
quests which led into the age of
apocalypse when legion went back in time
and intended to kill magneto and xavier
jumped in the way and died instead and
so it's one of these things where legion
has in a lot of instances cause more
problems for the x-men population than
he has any real benefit and so because
of the contentious relationship between
the two there really isn't a whole lot
of love loss here i mean there is to a
degree but really not a whole lot and so
ultimately xavier knows that like
there's something going on out there
right for some reason there's heightened
levels of rage and aggression among the
x-men population and initially he
thought that it possibly could have been
legion now when dave is like no that's
ridiculous it's not me then xavier
realizes you do know who it is and
legi's response is yes but i'm not going
to tell you and so what ends up
happening is that as he goes to leave
xavier basically scans the mind of
legion and realizes the onslaught entity
has returned which literally just bow
annihilates the entire place right just
destroys everybody there i mean look
like within a span of a few seconds the
entire place just descends into just
violence and destruction literally
onslaught just drives everybody to kill
each other that's basically what happens
the resurrection protocols are enacted
and of course people end up returning
now again for for their part it is kind
of bonkers here because the the reality
of legion coming back right xavier being
killed in the process literally
everybody dying the reality of this
happening is is a huge deal because even
then it seems as though professor x
doesn't still doesn't fully understand
and a lot of that's because remember
when a mutant dies they're brought back
based on the the most recent backup of
their memory and so essentially xavier's
mind was not backed up after at least in
that moment when when he had realized
what was going on with onslaught so when
he comes back he doesn't recall any of
that right all he knows is like
something happened and like 63 mutants
were all killed and sin and seemingly an
instant right and that's when the
question when he asked like you know who
did this right who killed all these
people then the answer is kind of like
ah that's kind of the thing because it's
believed that it was legion the belief
is that legion was the one who did it
and that's when xavier goes to mars
where legion is really just kind of
building up what is in effect a kind of
battleground a kind of arena for him to
basically confront onslaught by dragging
him to mars basically and the two of
them facing off when xavier shows up
here that you end up having uh end up
having a kind of conversation between
the two where legion's not really paying
any attention now you do have the the
twin sons zorn and zorn literally like
one of them has a star in their head and
the other one has a black hole the
important thing is if you were to
destroy one you'd probably wipe out the
entirety of the earth right that's kind
of where their power is uh but basically
like xavier is trying to talk to legion
and legion's just ignoring him right
he's kind of blowing him off the whole
time now for nightcrawler who legion is
actually talking to he's basically
dealing with a confrontation between
fabian cortez and lost right this is not
really an overly important part of the
comic it's kind of cool right because
it's basically them having to come to
terms with everything that's going on
lost accepting the fact that that fabian
cortez is the one who killed her family
and essentially having to learn to
forgive him and that fabian cortez
coming to grips with the fact that he's
basically hurt so many people and having
to having to be able to beg for
forgiveness that's kind of what's going
on with these two guys right uh the
fight's pretty pretty knocked down drag
out between the two and you really have
nightcrawler in between who's trying to
get everybody to understand what's going
on trying to get them to work together
and so on and so forth and so ultimately
he actually has this amazing moment
where he teleports the two of them into
the atmosphere right in the stratosphere
of of mars if you can call it that and
then in turn they just start falling
down to the ground now fabian cortez had
shut down the powers of lost and
basically they're all just gonna they're
all literally crashing to their deaths
because phoebe and cortez all he can do
is boost or take away other people's
powers he can't really give himself
powers right he can't give himself the
ability to fly or anything like that and
so ultimately he's like nightcrawlers
like here's what's gonna happen i'm
outside the sphere of influence of
fabian cortez so my powers are
unaffected but you guys are falling to
your deaths so either you can forgive
and you guys can move on or you can both
crash into the ground and die and hold
on to your hate forevermore and
ultimately you have this instance where
fabian cortez is kind of like okay cool
he basically realizes and accepts like
how you know what it is that he's been
doing over the course of his life how
he's been bringing harm to other people
and he basically starts trying to boost
the powers of lost the problem is
onslaught's in them and so ultimately
onslaught ends up pushing fabian cortez
to not only boost the powers of lost but
to do it to such a degree that he
basically kills her right that she
actually ends up dying and so they kind
of continue to crash down and so on but
the the effect that she had right the
boosting of her powers essentially
anchored the moon of mars so phobos is
now crashing down into the planet so
they got like 10 minutes to evacuate
onslaught literally created this kind of
chain reaction that's going to lead to
the destruction of this entire world and
so you have this really sort of cool
moment here where you basically end up
having legion who realizes how it is
that onslaught's coming back and how
expansive the involvement of onslaught
is and this is massive right so so what
legion ends up figuring out here is that
when one when kurt basically ends up uh
having his powers boosted by fabian
cortez so he can he can basically
teleport to the moon and then teleport
it away right despite the fact that it's
just a giant fireball at this point what
you also have is legion revealing here
that onslaught kind of exists in the
space between death and resurrection
that when a mutant out there is killed
and they go through the resurrection
process not every element of them is
brought back that in fact what xavier
and the five have been doing is bringing
back the best of that particular mutant
right so say for example that you had
somebody out there who was hell-bent on
death and destruction that if that
mutant died uh for whatever reason maybe
they had like a change of heart and they
saved the x-men from impending doom and
that person died in the process they'd
be worthy of resurrection but when they
were brought back that little segment of
them that evil aspect of them would be
left out onslaught feeds on that and so
the result is that's why he's been
getting more and more powerful it's
almost as if you are you have somebody
eating a plate of food and they leave
leftovers and just walk away onslaught's
basically feeding on the leftovers but
the psychic leftovers of all these
mutants who have been resurrected and
that's what's allowing him to become
more and more powerful so the reality is
his return doesn't really seem to be
anchored directly to charles xavier or
magneto it basically seems as though
he's kind of returning of his own accord
right and it makes sense because those
psycho psychic elements of xavier and
magneto still exist the entirety of
krakowa is rooted in frustration and
hatred for humanity right the entire
basis behind this nation's existence is
because the mutant population doesn't
trust humans and so because of this
they're kind of out doing their own
thing and so it makes perfect sense that
onslaught would eventually return even
if only through that particular method
now the other part of this is that
nightcrawler knows that when he's
resurrected that he's not going to
remember any of this and so he tells
fabian cortez when the time comes when
i'm brought back remind me of like this
this anchor remind me of this demon
being remind me of this like give me
this one particular phrase and
everything will start to return right
everything will come back to me and in
turn i will fully understand what's
going on right he calls it the spark
right like tell me about the spark and
basically that will recall or kind of
jog those memories in a nightcrawler and
remind him to go after david holler to
have david holler fill him in on
everything and so of course nightcrawler
is able to basically teleport phobos
away which is absolutely amazing right
that's kind of the crazy thing and then
this is one of those interesting moments
when phoebe and cortez boosts the powers
of nightcrawler nightcrawler sees it all
right he's like i see everything i see
how we win i see how we flourish i see
the path the way so seemingly it's like
he can see his own past you can see it
all coming together in a singular
picture but it also seems like there's a
bit of precognition that goes on there
now this is where things are a little
weird i'm really just kind of haphazard
guessing here because this is how you
end up having these small little moments
where a mutant gets elevated from being
just like an alpha level or gamma level
mutant possibly even a beta level mutant
to becoming an omega level mutant i
don't really know how you elevate
somebody like like nightcrawler from
being the the level that he is now to
omega level because literally he just
teleports through the brimstone
dimension to another location and that's
it right so maybe you can increase how
much mass he can teleport or something
like that teleporting an entire moon is
a big deal but at the very least the
most he could do is become somebody like
manifold who could teleport people
through like space and time right or
possibly to other dimensions and that
would be the extent of it and i don't
know if really teleporting somebody
across space and time would make
somebody omega level marvel could change
that and say that's the case who knows
but of course he ends up dying you know
because of of everything going on right
i mean basically sacrificing his life
one you know being burned alive what
little life he has left she's kind of
being snuffed out as he's in like the
coldness of space and so on but he ends
up coming back now the question he
immediately asks is worse fabian cortez
right what's going on with fabian
quartets the problem and we're not
really giving a definitive explanation
here fabian cortez is in a catatonic
state we don't know how he got there we
simply just know that he is right now it
may very well be that onslaught had a
hand in this that onslaught had screwed
up the mind of fabian cortez it could be
that charles xavier was the one who
didn't and seemingly that might entirely
be the case that charles xavier is the
one who screwed up the mind of fabian
cortez and that would kind of make sense
because if onslaught is in the mind of
charles xavier and his full-on taken
over charles even if charles doesn't
fully know right so he exists in like
his subconscious then he would in turn
wipe the mind of fabian cortez just
leave him there and when fabian is
brought back he's not going to remember
anything about what nightcrawler told
him remind me of the spark and so on and
so forth he's not gonna remember any of
that stuff so it's gonna fall on
nightcrawler to seek out legion if he
even remembers to do that but at the
moment there's no real explanation here
in terms of what happened what we do
know is that onslaught is alive and well
among everybody and in fact it even
looks like he's in charles xavier and
every single mutant on krakow and so
what this does is this continues on it
basically ends way of x as far as i'm
aware i'm not i'm not aware of there
being like a continuation of the way of
x i think it was designed to be a mini
series i don't think it's an ongoing
series but basically it goes into the
onslaught revelation seemingly we're
onslaught will full on return but this
is how onslaught's rising right this is
how onslaught has been has been
returning in marvel comics and i'm
excited for it man i'm excited for
onslaught coming back because let me
tell you something that's on man i'm
gonna tell you so onslaught is legit i
love onslaught so much
[Laughter]
he's just unbridled just rage
frustration and power right this guy is
just he's it's it's crazy how powerful
he is but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end and i
will catch you all later
peace